foreign
Chad joins us up next in San Antonio
Chad welcome to the show
hey guys thank you very much I
appreciate it sure how can we help my
question today is
I'm not having a disagreement at all
with my wife but I'm just thinking about
this and wanted your thoughts on it it's
quite the disclaimer I believe you go
ahead no really
um she's wanting to buy a investment
property to use it as a rental on the
coast why I don't have a problem with
that why uh to invest money and get a
little bit now where did you hear about
this
she saw it like an Instagram video or a
tick tock or something
we actually have a place down there
already a vacation home of our own and
it's a new development that's coming
about okay and it seems like a pretty
good deal but my question to you or your
thoughts I'm guessing is
they're they're saying that we could
Finance with them whatever and they
would lock Us in but if it won't go
higher than seven percent so my question
is I'm not scared of an investment I'm
not scared of putting it in real estate
but do I put more money down do I walk
away from it completely
I just kind of wanted to get your
thoughts there I'm not out of debt I I
do owe money on my home which I owe
roughly 250 on my property and it's
worth north of Amelia
other than that I'm debt free so no
Consumer Debt just a mortgage on your
personal
that is correct okay
well we would tell you to pay off your
primary residence first and then pay for
any investment property in cash
and that is super conservative and super
not cool in today's culture
because you know what that means you're
like that's like six ten years from now
boring I want the money now the problem
is you're gonna go you're gonna be over
a half million dollars in debt how much
is this new property
roughly 400. do you owe on your other
beach house
no it's paid for okay
and how often are you going to this
beach house
uh twice a month at least oh nice do you
rent it out in between or is this just
for you guys
personal use only okay
well you got the paid for rental house
what's that worth or the vacation
property
um
150
it's worth 150. okay and you owe 250
what's your income
uh combined we're this year is going to
be probably three and a quarter way to
go
fantastic income so the question is
making three and a quarter how quickly
could we pay off 250 and then save up
another 400.
yeah so that's 650 you guys make 325 a
year how much of that can go towards
these uh these exciting dreams you have
well I've got I've got some I've got
enough to pay off my home in the bank
oh and it's one of those scary things I
was listening to the last caller you
talk about Doomsday Preppers and my
wife's like well I'd rather keep it in
the bank where we know where it's at how
much money do you have in the bank
roughly 370. why Chad dude why what are
you doing man
how should I invest it you should pay
your house off
that the the the your you have a tax
every month we can just call it your
prepper tax
which is the APR on your home
you are paying you are paying every
month to not pay your house off
like in in a in a major event
not owing anybody anything
and being out of work let's say covet
hits again and everybody can't go to
work for 70 or 60 days or 120 days or
whatever and the country's broke it is
and they can't just mail checks anymore
the person who doesn't owe anybody
anything is going to be better off than
the person who suddenly can't make any
payments is that fair
yes so having 370
000 in the bank in your bank while
you're paying somebody else interest on
money they've they just it just
clinically insane it doesn't make any it
doesn't make any sense if you had twenty
five thousand dollars in cash on top of
your emergency fund just as an extra
like oh man just in case I could go with
you there I'm enough of a prepper to get
that are you 25 000 bucks under your
mattress gotcha I'm with you on that
but dude
just pay your house off me pay your
house off man and the the idea of having
this rental house with a mortgage on it
means your profits are going to be real
Slim which means you're better off
making your 325 than you are making a
thousand dollars if you're lucky and
profits on this rental house
making 12 a year right yes so walk out
the scenario with me you have 370 at the
bank we pay off the house today that
leaves you with 120. let's call 20 of
that your emergency fund that leaves you
with a hundred right
yes the the rental property you want is
400 which means you have a 300 000 Gap
you make 325. could you save three
hundred thousand dollars in less than
two years making 325 with no payments in
the world say yes
so now we're looking at this with a very
different lens you called in saying I'm
concerned about interest rates now we're
not concerned about anything and by the
way if you have if we have six to seven
percent interest rates which is what
buying a house is right now
um
if you in the house cost 400 Grand if
you show up to that scenario with 375
000 in cash and say I'll buy it right
now they'll sell it to you
and wealthy people with cash don't care
about interest rates because it it
doesn't apply to them
it applies to people who are who are
having to work through a bank to make
their day a little bit brighter you see
how you just opt out of the whole system
this way
yes and that's how the wealthy hang on
to their money because they have cash
when other people are having to scramble
to and the the market slows down because
of interest rates the wealthy can come
in and buy stuff with cash at much
cheaper prices and that's how the
wealthy get wealthier
all righty gosh so it sounds like we're
a year and a half away from getting a
rental house Chad did twitch make you
sad
no it doesn't are you going to pay off
your house today please say yes that
would be so cool for a guy that hasn't
paid off his house yet do it for me man
do it for John
I'm not going to do anything without
talking to her I know better than that
ah very that was a trap you passed the
test well played pay your house off man
this is a different conversation now for
Chad he gets to go to his wife and say
honey we're gonna get that rental house
but it's gonna take a little while yes
give us 18 months and that means we're
paying off the house today that frees us
up completely we have a hundred thousand
in the banks still towards this house
and we make 325 we can put away 150 to
200. every year which means we're going
to have this money within the next 18
months a lot and we're not going to owe
anything which means every single dime
that comes in is now profits yes after
our expensive our after our expenses and
that to me man there's such freedom in
that I remember
um and again I don't buy into all of the
investment strategies but I remember a
conversation with Charlie Munger and
Warren Buffett and they said what's the
number one strategy for invest like
what's the number one thing I could do
for investing
and I think it was Charlie Munger that
said have 10 million dollars in your
checking account
because you never know and be able to be
the first guy at the table with a check
and say I'll buy that right now and you
will get an extraordinary deal from
somebody who needs to sell something
you'll give them a gift of getting rid
of the thing you'll get an incredible
deal and you don't have to go to a bank
or raise money or whatever have 10
million dollars in your checking account
I'm a long way I've got ten dollars in
my checking account but this idea that
dude interest rates don't apply to you
if you're paying with cash you don't
have to worry about what the economy is
doing you just you've got a giant pile
of money that's right that's a good
problem to have but Chad's done a great
job man we are cheering you on excited
for this rental house in the near future
this is the Ramsay show